of course there was some Iranian role
Iran provides money to Hamas it provides
it's trid dismal weapons into Gaza for
years uh it provides the group with
blueprints for making drones for making
Rockets some of which we saw used
against Israel on Saturday so in that
sense there is an Iranian role I think
there was also a degree of coordination
in that Hamas wouldn't do something like
this something that might draw in other
groups around the region like hasah in
Lebanon it wouldn't do something like
this without alerting Iran and aler
other militia groups in the neighborhood
so I think likely there was some degree
of coordination quite late in the game
but the idea that Iran might have
directed this organized this been the
the prime mover behind this attack we
haven't seen any evidence to support
that and the the Israeli Army spokesman
went on television this morning and said
they haven't seen any evidence of direct
Iranian involvement so that's a very
categorical statement coming from the
military itself